there's this never-ending conversation
that basically just happens in talking
points everybody just says their talking
points and then we never get anywhere
and it has to do with mass shootings and
supposed good guys with guns and the way
it usually works
someone will ultimately say after some
shooting the reason that this shooting
happened or was as deadly as it was is
not too many guns or too much access to
guns it's too few guns we need more good
guys with guns so that they can either
prevent or more quickly stop these mass
shooting incidents now this of course
ignores that most shooting incidents are
not mass shooting incidents their
individual homicides and suicides but
putting that aside for a second someone
will then inevitably inevitably come
back and say well where were the good
guys with guns because a lot of these
shootings are happening in places where
it is relatively easy to get a concealed
carry permit for example they didn't
stop the shooting and then the pro-gun
side will come back and they'll say well
it was a gun-free zone which only
prevents good guys from having guns the
bad guys are gonna ignore the rules and
bring the guns anyway and then we never
get anywhere so let's sort of try to
step back from the generalities of those
talking points for a second and talk
specifically about Texas and Ohio in
these particular cases and disclaimer
this video is going to be demonetised by
YouTube as I told you yesterday all week
we've been trying to have serious adult
conversations about crime and violence
in society those stories are all
instantly demonetised
by YouTube this is probably our twelfth
D monetization this week so the reality
about the good guy with a gun is that he
can rarely if ever stopped a mass
shooting this got traction after Sandy
Hook in 2012 the NRA vice-president then
vice-president I don't know if he still
is Wayne LaPierre said the only way to
stop a bad guy with a gun is a good guy
with a gun and then people started
talking about arming teachers and guns
in more places and it just doesn't work
it's not even a myth it's really a
delusion the reality is the opposite of
the talking point in a ton of cases
armed so-called good guys with guns in
public places are likely to make mass
shootings worse experts agree ok
Stanford Law Professor John Donoghue
says quote unless you're very well
trained this means like military level
training you usually add more to the
body count than you subtract you don't
need to think too imaginatively to
understand why this is there's a bad guy
with a gun
it starts shooting 30 to 60 seconds
later a good guy with a gun if he can
even figure out what's going on and who
to shoot starts shooting back another 30
to 60 seconds later like in Ohio where
police responded very quickly police
show up they see two people shooting and
now there are two guys with guns that
police have to assess who's good who's
bad police required to fire more shots
to take down the bad guy if they can
even figure out who that is of which
there are now possibly two as far as
police are concerned it's chaos it leads
to more injury it leads to more death so
then now let's look more specifically at
Texas and Ohio in the last few years
both states have expanded gun rights
they've made it easier to concealed
carry in Ohio 2017 you can then you you
were then allowed to start bringing guns
to daycare centers on private planes
employees are allowed to bring guns in
Ohio to company parking lots for example
in Texas ten new expansive gun laws that
we discussed on the bonus show this week
are being added almost as we speak of
fewer than four weeks from now and
meanwhile we see that armed civilians
responding to mass shooters in public
places to prevent shootings basically
don't exist
you'll hear some few anecdotal cases but
even in cases where someone with a gun
starts shooting back hypothetically the
shootings typically lasts very little
time 30 60 seconds of actual shootings
sometimes you do get a few minutes no
one reacts the way they think they would
even police who are trained often don't
react as expected and in a chaotic live
shooter scenario the good guy with a gun
is simply another guy with a gun to
police
Joe Hendry the director of risk
assessments and a national trainer at
the Alice training institute says quote
it's a very difficult
to shoot in a room that's full of people
while someone is shooting at you when
police show up the shooting is underway
or it's over more shooters in these
scenarios do not help when even police
don't react as training would dictate
they should what do you think the
average person is going to do the
average person even with gun safety
training and even some response training
will either do nothing or they will
panic and shoot the wrong people or get
themselves shot by police when police
arrive security guards they're not
military they're not police we're
talking about guards in schools armed
guards and schools can you imagine and
then think about scenarios where it
doesn't even make a difference look at
the Las Vegas shooting what good were
good guys with guns to stop a guy in a
hotel room with high-powered weapons
Ohio itself look at what happened in
Ohio over the weekend near instantaneous
response by trained police the entire
thing lasted a minute the guy killed a
ton of people and some people call it
the good guy with a gun myth it's really
a fantasy or a delusion as I said
earlier the number one thing we can do
to fix the gun issue and gun deaths is
fix our culture so that fewer people see
guns as the way to solve a problem or
prove a political point or as an outlet
for distress that they're experiencing
when they say let's talk about mental
health as the cause well then fund it
you can't say the issue is mental health
and then do nothing to increase access
to mental health treatment and by the
way I mean this I don't even want to get
into this but if the issue is mental
health as some claim it to be you then
need a system to block people with
certain conditions from having guns
which many Republicans are against
anyway and it also opens up a very quite
frankly complex conversation about which
diagnoses preclude you from having a gun
and that's a whole other topic would the
right be okay with saying anyone
diagnosed with adjustment disorder which
is sort of like this catch-all generic
mental health diagnosis that's often
used merely to get insurance coverage
for mental health treatment does that
preclude you from having a gun does
anxiety preclude you from having a gun
what about depression
there's anyone on antidepressants get
banned from having guns I mean the the
the it's a mental health issue ignores
number one that the people claiming that
don't really want to fund access to
mental health typically and number two
that what exactly would be the mechanism
and conditions that would preclude you
from having a gun a conversation for a
different day